i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from a washington on edge tonight
now
i'm going to say this
very bluntly
with their refusal to forthrightly
unequivocally condemn
these terroristic tactics of their
activist democrat base
the democrats the white house they're
putting the lives of supreme court
justices in jeopardy yes i mean it in
jeopardy
now a party that spent the past what 16
months branding the gop as as a bunch of
insurrectionists
they're now carrying out by proxy
an insurrection of their own
against the federal judiciary we got to
be a menace to our enemies and our
enemies as anybody that's attacking our
reproductive freedoms we will not turn
back bless us we are weary we are mad as
hell
[Music]
of course the criticisms of the opinion
are dishonest constitutionally and
fraudulent factually
the abortion issue is merely returned to
the states we talked about this over the
last few nights
and that is where
the voters of those states will then
determine the outcome for abortion it
might be regulated it might be outlawed
it might be allowed in certain cases or
in the first trimester it might be
banned
so it's not going to be a
one-size-fits-all coast to coast
but the left doesn't want the voters to
have a say and they don't care about
facts or principles
for them that leak of the draft opinion
itself orchestrated and and disseminated
as it was
it's meant to terrorize
not to influence
think about this why would someone leak
what was a three-month-old draft opinion
that was already in some foreign form or
another coming out probably in june
anyway
and tonight though given everything i've
seen everything i know about the court
and its inner workings from the time i
clerked
uh i'm going to say that i believe this
leak was done
with the goal
of stoking violence against the
conservative justices primarily on the
court
in other words the goal
to force a change in the court's makeup
before the november election sounds
nefarious i know it sounds like a
totally horrifying prospect
but those who believe that dismembering
third trimester babies is somehow a
sacred right protected in the
constitution
could those people very well be capable
of rationalizing other insidious acts
now why aren't politicians in both
parties speaking out against what is an
obvious effort
to interfere with or intimidate the
judicial process
now remember what biden promised us
remember on his inauguration day
today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together
uniting our people united in our nation
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
we can join forces
stop the shouting and lower the
temperature
did he see what was happening in front
of the court or in new york or
see any of that or is he just tuned out
so where are biden's calming wards words
now
do you think
the progressive activists that are now
planning protests outside some of the
justices houses are extreme
peaceful protest
no peaceful protest is not extreme
activists posted a map with the home
addresses of the supreme court justices
is that the kind of thing this president
wants to help your side make their point
look i think the president's view is
that there's a lot of passion a lot of
fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected
that's it
nothing about going to people's homes we
want the privacy respect
spell it out for us what's going on
president biden and his party
have whipped up the ugliest radicals in
their base
and they give lip service to privacy oh
please
as we reported last night conservative
justices homes their locations
they've been shared online peter ducey
referenced that
and now they're receiving targeted
personal phone threats
justice alito author of that draft
majority opinion
canceled a scheduled appearance thursday
in nashville
at the fifth circuit judicial conference
i mean i don't think he should have i
think he should have gone and you you
can't give in to these thugs
justice thomas spoke today at the 11th
circuit judicial conference
friends there told me he was unbowed
and as friendly as always to all who
approached him but nevertheless the risk
is real to the justice's safety
according to one senator it's been
reported
so if anything should happen
to any of the justices or their family
members
the blood the suffering the pain will be
on the hands of the white house and all
the senators and pro-abortion fanatics
who so recklessly whipped americans up
into this frenzy on false grounds
as usual the incitement that they accuse
others of
is what they themselves practice hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else